♪ ♪ ♪
- Après le succès de votre roman
"Un viol l'ordinaire",
vous revenez avec la suite.
"Un homme, tout simplement".
Votre souhait, c'était
d'aider les hommes.
- Exactement.
- Comment et pourquoi?
JANETTE BERTRAND, autrice
- Parce que je voulais
m'adresser aux hommes.
Les hommes ne vont pas
chez les psys. Les hommes
ne vont pas chez... s'ils font
une dépression, peut-être.
Mais pas pour des problèmes
de couple. Les hommes ne vont
pas chez les psys. Si c'est
un homme, ils vont dire :
"Il va me juger, il va me
trouver faible." Ils n'y vont
pas. Avec une femme, il y a
toujours de la séduction qui
rentre. "Je vais l'avoir, c'est
une femme. Je vais la séduire.
Je vais savoir où sont
ses faiblesses. Je vais
l'avoir." Alors que les groupes
d'hommes, c'est extraordinaire.
♪ ♪ ♪
Alors, ce livre-là,
c'est fait pour les hommes.
Puis, s'ils le lisent pas,
tant pis pour eux autres.
(rire)
- "Un homme, tout simplement"
a demandé six mois de recherche
pour vous.
- Oh mon Dieu, oui!
- C'est ça à peu près?
- Mais oui parce que
je m'attaque à des sujets,
des fois, que je ne connais pas.
Comme la justice réparatrice,
je connaissais pas ça.
On ne va pas se vanter d'être
allé à la justice réparatrice.
J'avais, oui, j'étais allée
en médiation pour un litige de
maison, et puis j'avais trouvé
que la médiation, c'était
quelque chose d'extraordinaire.
Puis bon, je me suis renseignée.
Et je suis quelqu'un qui va
se renseigner et qui appelle
les gens. Tout ça, il faut que
je l'emmagasine pour être
capable après de faire
un roman avec ça.
Si je dis le mot "clochard",
est-ce que ça vous choque?
- Pas pour moi.
- Non? Toi, Gérard,
ça te choque pas, toi?
- Avec vos émissions de télé
comme "Parler pour parler",
"Avec un grand A",
vous avez vraiment misé sur
la communication pour rapprocher
les gens. C'est la solution,
moi, je pense.
- C'est la solution, se parler.
Or, nos hommes, en général,
pas tous, ne parlent pas.
Même ceux qui parlent ne
parlent... Tu peux parler du
hockey et tu peux parler, tu
peux parler de la Chine, et puis
des... ce qui se passe entre
pays, mais tu peux ne pas être
capable de parler à ta blonde.
- J'ai couché avec Lucie Émond!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ce que j'ai beaucoup aimé
de votre dernier livre, c'est
qu'il est écrit de façon assez
simple, justement pour rejoindre
le plus d'hommes possible.
C'était vraiment votre souhait,
ça, que Monsieur et Madame
Tout-le-Monde, finalement,
puisse comprendre, et agir,
et changer peut-être
ses comportements.
- Bien, je ne m'adresse pas...
je ne me suis jamais adressé
à une élite, parce qu'ils ont
les moyens, et physiques et
financiers, de se renseigner.
Je prends tous les autres, tous
les autres, et on est nombreux
à être dans les autres, je ne
me considère pas dans l'élite.
C'est sûr que toute ma vie,
j'ai un peu souffert de ne pas
être ni psychologue ni...
J'aurais voulu avoir un gros
titre. J'étais journaliste. Bon,
je l'ai fait à ma façon. À ma
façon, faire ça, c'est faire du
journalisme aussi. Se renseigner
pendant six mois, c'est faire du
journalisme, et avoir le talent
d'en faire une histoire.
♪ ♪ ♪
- En lisant "Un homme, tout
simplement", je me suis posé
la question : comment, à 96 ans,
Jeannette Bertrand réussit
à trouver l'énergie et la force
d'écrire encore comme ça?
- Quand je suis partie
de l'école Gédéon-Ouimet,
en 7e année, la plupart
des petites filles de ma classe
allaient travailler.
À 12 ans, 13 ans. Alors moi,
j'ai demandé à mon père de faire
des études, comme mes frères.
Puis, il a-tu essayé
de me décourager en m'offrant
toutes sortes d'affaires.
Et puis, il m'a dit :
"Pauvre fille, tu vas...
tu vas t'instruire pour quoi?
Pour laver des couches?"
C'était ça que les pères
disaient. J'ai dit :
"Oui. Je laverai des couches,
mais je saurai des affaires."
Alors, j'ai lavé des couches
aussi, mais... et tout
en apprenant des choses.
J'ai... Moi, j'apprends.
J'aime apprendre. J'apprends
et je remets aux autres.
C'est ça, ma vie.
C'est très simple.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Depuis que je suis entré
chez vous, je vois des piles
de papiers comme ça.
(rire de Jeannette)
Il y a des manuscrits partout.
Ça, c'est visiblement
votre projet "Écrire sa vie",
vous avez demandé aux aînés
d'écrire leur vie.
- Oui! Je leur ai fait
confiance.
- Vous êtes rendue à combien?
- 2000.
- 2000. J'en ai lu... j'ai dit :
"Je vais en lire 2-3."
J'ai passé un été à lire
du matin au soir.
C'est tellement passionnant!
C'est notre histoire!
C'est notre histoire.
- Mais vous allez faire quoi
avec tout ça?
- Ah, je vais faire un livre.
- Pas un autre livre!
- Oui. Oui. Le prochain livre,
il est déjà commencé,
et je ne suis pas seule,
je suis avec Laurent Turcot,
historien, qui est un...
qui est extraordinaire.
Et on va écrire l'histoire
de ma naissance à aujourd'hui.
1925.
- Jeannette Bertrand, merci
pour ce magnifique entretien.
Merci.
- Merci.
♪ ♪